you visited China for the film for the
first time first time you've been to
China how did you how did you enjoy
China well it was it's very very
different
everything is everything's different
yeah the questions they say things like
you are cute
yes always say yes yes they always say
yes yes yeah yeah and like the other
questions are weird and they have a
nickname for me I learned big elderly
cousin your nickname is Jamie's big
elderly cousin I'm super flattered yeah
yeah and they call Josh baby Josh which
he loves that's fantastic yeah a big
cousin and I'm like yeah yeah that's me
I'm here I'm here for you you also went
to Spain where I'm told that you heard
the voice of the person who does your
movies in Spain I heard my Spanish self
for the first time and we were doing a
talk show like this yeah that in Spanish
and I heard the voice it was just like
it's so high-pitched and different from
my own voice it was you could do it it's
[Applause]
I'm very offended but I do want that gig
if you want me if you want me to that
boy so you met my natural I think we all
went that way
I think the audience went right there
sorry I just thought you'd be funny if
it'd be funny if your films in Spain
were dubbed by me speaking normally it
would be closer
[Laughter]